[Music]
let's go out to Little Rock and talk to
Ashley what's up
Ashley hi good morning Dr John how are
you we're so good how about you I I'm
doing great I I am a little nervous I
have to tell you but I'm I'm very
grateful for your time today don't be
nervous I'm not that good I'm not good
at this what's up so I'm calling because
I I have a lot of uh conflicting
feelings of guilt and resentment toward
my mom that I'm hoping you can help me
work through what' she do um so I'll
I'll try to be succinct but basically my
my parents had a very tumultuous
marriage during which my dad was
unfaithful pretty much throughout that
entire relationship and he was a
emotionally and and on one occasion
physically abusive with her as well and
after they split up and and my dad left
you know my mom really stepped up to
take care of me and my brother so I've
always held her in a very high regard
because of that um but the guilt and
resentment comes in uh because I I moved
I moved away um I moved out of state
with my boyfriend a few years ago and in
my culture that's kind of unusual and
and frown upon I guess and so she's
really kind of guilted me of for that
over the years and um has badmouthed me
and my relationship to various family
members and and friends um and I think
I've just realized how much she's put on
me uh to kind of take care of her
emotionally throughout my life so I I am
struggling because I um love her to
death but I I have a lot of anger toward
her um that I I don't really know how to
work through I guess to put it in short
no I appreciate that so I wonder if the
anger that you have towards
her is potentially a more Universal
anger
that I wanted this picture to be
celebrated by everybody and it's not so
I wonder if your anger is actually
grief I that may be part of it I think
there's there's more to the anger if I
can give you a couple of sure examples
perhaps so um for instance in the one uh
instance where my dad was physical with
her you know she um I I was maybe 11 and
it it happened in front of me and and
she asked months and months later you
know why I didn't do anything to stop
him at the time um and she also doesn't
have a lot of people to her so she chose
to confide in me and my brother you know
throughout my dad's uh affair with his
mistress and now wife so she would tell
us you know all of the updates and show
us emails and like text messages between
them um so I I think just putting that
on us as young kids has made me feel um
I I don't know conflicted in the the
appreciation that I have for her but a
lot of anger in the way that you know
know she's dealt with me moving out but
also just how she's kind of dealt with
my parents relationship um as we were
growing up that's
like I'm sorry that happened that should
never have
happened she shouldn't have done that to
her
kids and that was never y'all's burden
to
carry the challenge is with our
parents as can we hold the good stuff
and can we hold the bad stuff at the
same time and what do we choose to do
with those
things
and I I was on the phone with my mom as
I was driving in this morning I love my
mom I love my dad I love my
in-laws but they don't get a vote into
how I choose to deal with the
emotions and you've got some of these
parts of your mom that were amazing and
she was so strong and she survived what
was
hell and she dragged her little kids
through it
too both in both stories are
true where where the next step breaks
down is you're still going back to your
mom trying to solve that dilemma and
that's not her Dilemma to all it's yours
in the same way she was bringing you
along why did you protect me from
this which she should have never done no
parent should put that on 11-year-old
little girl my
God no piece of crap Dad should hit
their
mother especially in front of a kid no
I'm not gonna say especially just ever
but also not in front of a kid like all
of
it but in the same way right now you're
holding your grief you're holding your I
can't believe this happened
and you're circling back and trying to
get your mom to solve it she
can't and so but I don't know how to
work through it myself yeah well and
you've probably heard me use this
analogy a lot
but as a little kid you were born into a
household and you had a backpack on and
your dad kept dropping bricks in that
backpack and a couple times your mom and
your dad put cinder blocks in that
back and you've been carrying that
sucker around not to mention your
boyfriend and those breakups and the
stupid thing that your girlfriend told
you one time and your own things that
you've experienced right and now how old
are you 28 28 with a backpack that
weighs 5,000 lbs and it's so
heavy and instead of taking the bricks
out of your backpack and just setting
them down I'm not carrying this
anymore you're hunched over trying to
hold this thing up and your legs are
shaking and your shoulders are burning
and you're looking at your mom asking
her why she put him in there that's who
I mean she
did there will never be an answer that
takes the weight off of your back that's
your job that's your venture to go
do so one of the things I often tell
people is to literally go to the
store go to Home Depot or Lowe's and buy
a cinder block and put a piece of duct
tape on
it and write
down the time you called me in and ask
me why I didn't stand between an abusive
man and
me and I want you to walk around your
backyard and just carry that thing until
it's so heavy it's hard to
hold then I want you to go find a place
in your
backyard and set it down and rip the the
the thing on throw it down and never
pick it up again but have this cathartic
like you know you go to a funeral
there's a before and after and the
funerals are so important because
because it gives your body an anchor
point a period at the end of a
sentence and we can shift from person to
Spirit like this this like you now
you're a part of my memory you're a part
of me but I can't pick up a phone and
call you what you're doing is a very
similar thing mom you put this back this
brick in my backpack I'm not carrying
your stuff anymore no
more and then I want you to write a
letter to that 11-year-old little girl
and tell her that you're sorry that she
went through that cuz she should have
had a mom that didn't drag her through
through that and she should have had a
dad that didn't beat up her mom and that
didn't fill the house with so much fear
and didn't cheat on Mom and drag other
women through
right there's 11-year-old little girl
trying to figure out what was so bad
about her that Dad took off and there's
an 11-year-old little girl trying to
figure out oh man maybe I should have
done something for a
mom and it was never that little girl's
job so I have a a question about
that um if I how how can I continue to
have my mom in my life you know right
now I I have so much dread when I think
about going home
um feel that way your mom has opted out
on
you because she continually belittles
you in the choices you've
made she continues to talk bad about you
if behavior is language she is telling
you I don't want to be in relationship
with you until you do what I want you to
do to make me feel better about
myself and I would tell you it's
unethical to continue to go home when
you resent her for going that's on
you so you hear me say all the time
choose guilt over resentment every
time and so practice this
year I think I've I think I've said on
the show every September my f my wife
and I send an email out to the family
here's what our travel plans are going
to be for Thanksgiving and Christmas and
it's usually based on a conversation my
wife and I have what's the tra what's my
travel season been like what's her
writing season been like what's our kids
like schedules been like and what's our
financial situation this year like what
are we going to do but we get to pick
that and then if my mom decides to gets
super angry and mad she's a grown woman
she gets to do
that that's her choice that's not I
can't fix that for
her and if you listen to your the
language that you're speaking you're
still on 11-year-old little girl trying
to figure out how to make Mom
okay and I want you to hear me say you
can't you never
could and well here's my promise if you
broke up with that boyfriend and you
moved back home
mom would have a comment about your
weight mom would have a comment about
your job Mom would wonder why you're
driving that car mom would wonder why
because that Finish Line's always going
to move because your mom's not okay with
who your mom is and she's dubbed you the
person to make it
right and you
can't you see what I'm
saying I do I just I feel guilty
thinking about I know you do leaving her
I guess you're not leaving her she left
you a long time ago Ashley she's using
you now to feel better about
herself she doesn't love the Ashley that
is living her life in Little Rock
Arkansas she loves the version of Ashley
that she wants Ashley to be so that she
can tell people at The Rotary Club I
don't know if she goes to Rotary Club
but whatever
right yeah you're a chess piece in her
game and do I think she loves you of
course she does do I think she's an
exhausted abused woman absolutely yes
has she been through hell no question
about
it but that's her work to choose to
do and by the way I don't think this has
to be some big announcement some big
grandiose talk I think it's hey we're
not traveling this year for the holidays
we'll FaceTime in and we're really going
to miss
you
and if that causes a lot of drama then
she gets to I mean that's her drama to
to cause and if she really wants to sit
down and have a conversation we can do
that in person we can do that if she
wants to come
visit or maybe on the phone Mom you've
made it super clear for the last four
years you don't like me you don't like
my
life you didn't like me when I was 11
and I wasn't able to defend you you you
haven't ever liked
me
so let's stop the dance and the charade
if we want to build something new a new
mother daughter relationship I'm all
in but I'm tired of you thinking less of
me I'm tired of you not liking me I'm
tired of you not loving
me for who I am I'm
tired and stop carrying that brick
around there is no way through this let
me say it this way you're going to have
to choose your hard path there's no easy
path
out you can choose your heart and go to
Thanksgiving and Christmas and have her
not like you and have her go through the
things and complain about everything and
why didn't you oh my gosh can you
believe your dad that one time you can
do that that's hard that's a hard way to
live or you can do another hard thing
which is to make some pretty firm
boundaries treat her with love and
dignity and respect and and at the same
time treat yourself with love and
dignity dignity and
respect and go about living a life
that's going to make you
whole not go on living a life that you
can try to play whack-a-mole with your
mom's emotions and feelings and try to
make her feel good about her life you
can't but there is no easy path there's
no way that you feel feel super great
but just because you don't feel great
doesn't mean it's not the right move
I'm going to send you a copy of building
a non-anxious life I want you to read
this book for you for the first time for
you and I want you to begin to look at
these choices these six daily choices
you can
make how could I begin
to invite warmth and laughter and joy
and peace into my home and I think for
you it's going to be starting with
owning reality choosing
reality choosing this fact that like
this is but I got and I got to choose to
do something
different I wish I had like some like oh
yeah just call her and say this but
that's not the way this
works it's you deciding I'm going to
choose reality I'm going to take
ownership of my life and if Mom's opted
out I hate that I got to grieve
it but I want more from me you're worth
it